[Applause]
all right here we are in overtime
marianne for you you've been evasive
about your political future lately but
you're a champion of progressive
candidates and ideas could you see
yourself potentially being an effective
leader
in congress
well you ran for president what about
congress i guess is the question i
actually ran for congress once oh you
did yeah
that didn't win that one either
what year was that uh 2014.
oh so what's the answer
i don't know what i'm going to do you
don't know what you're going to do come
on no i think you're in your own head 24
hours a day and never i think about it
of course i think about it but a lot of
people think about running some of them
will and some of them won't
well what are the problems when you're
in position to do it i sure would tax
you more
well you know oh marianne i think she
wouldn't be too bad there i think you
should be like john i think she should
be like john quincy okay eventually he
became a congressman after becoming
president and he did it well then i have
to become president and then exactly i
think you should go in that order yeah
that's what i say second john quincy
adams but you do you do see like we did
that issue tonight about
the ppp program 800 billion dollars it's
outrageous i know but do you understand
why people who pay a lot it's because
the rich do pay the most taxes i mean
look i'm saying that's not right of
course the rich should pay the most
taxes but you understand why people go
like what am i i'm giving up all this
money i mean i don't remember the last
year i paid less than more less than
half i pay more than half i'm not a you
know i'm not amazon for the army of
lawyers i'm just one guy hgo's very
generous but the government i'm in the
39
federal california takes 13. that's over
half you take over half and you still
have everything [ __ ] up you understand
why people are like well i i would give
it except you will [ __ ] it up oh you
think you really think that most people
well i'm just saying when we did the
issue three 800 billion dollars and only
a quarter of it went where it should so
look i don't think capitalism is a
perfect system but i think it is the
least imperfect system of allocating
capital because when you leave it to the
government it actually hurts the very
people who it is supposed to help in the
first place you actually saw
billionaires print much more money over
the course of the pandemic precisely
because of these government policies
that then fed a stock market that became
addicted to loose monetary policy and
lose fiscal policy that guess what make
stocks go up and who owns stocks rich
people okay so no surprise that there's
a populist outrage both on the right and
the left but we need to find a different
way of ultimately separating politics
from letting free market capitalism be
free market capitalism if some guy ends
up with more green pieces of paper than
the others so be it as long as we're all
equal in a democratic system of
governance that's what i think
i feel like this table i feel like this
table is a bunch of french arrest
aristocrats a week before the masses uh
made it to the best deal this is not
about what you think it's not about what
you think because you are
and and i listen i'm very glad free
market capitalism has been wonderful to
you wonderful to you it hasn't been bad
to me i understand the high side of this
party if you're in the party it's
wonderful not enough people can get into
the party today we're saying the same
thing there we're saying the same thing
they're locked up by government policy
that actually favors the people who are
in charge
again with the ppp thing it's not that
we're i'm i'm gonna i'll give you half
but then what are you doing with it
you're not giving it to the people i
wanted to go to you're giving it back to
these [ __ ] buying jet skis you know
that's what
most of the people most of the people
who do not want to pay higher taxes who
have a lot of money are not complaining
about where the ppp loans went they
you know as martin luther king said if
they give it to poor people they call it
a handout if they give it to rich people
they call it a substance but this didn't
go to poor people that's the whole point
it did not go to the warping point so
are you but those same rich people are
the ones who do not want to pay for
instance something like
president biden if he wanted to could
declare a national medical emergency and
expand medicare to everyone tonight if
president biden wanted to he could
cancel all the time i'm glad you brought
that up tonight the next question that
we are sent in why isn't universal
healthcare making any progress even a
liberal state like california the
majority of people want it and you said
not because of the insurance companies
the majority of americans no i didn't
say that
not just
that's what happened in california it
was that million-dollar check from the
insurance companies well it's also the
pharmaceutical companies the
pharmaceutical companies make more than
the insurance companies a lot more and
their their goal is not to make you
healthy is to sell drugs
so
i actually think that
i actually think there's truth to a lot
of what you guys are saying but at the
end of the day they're able to deflect
accountability for these questions by
actually changing the subject that's a
big part of what we were talking about
with this cultural elitism is ultimately
part of the reason that you see pfizer
decide or give big corporation decide
that there's going to be a certain
number of people who are going to staff
its ranks who are diverse these are the
press releases you see from
pharmaceutical companies today not
actually how we're going to bring down
the cost of drugs
can i interject the little factual that
i recall i may not have the facts
exactly right but they have done
this they've studied this why can't we
have universal because it is popular as
an idea in california people want to in
the united states okay but when they do
when they crunch the numbers here in
california of what it would cost to have
universal health care
it's like
taxes would have to be like 80 percent
for everybody or
insanely you
the numbers and that's why they give up
on it well the numbers just don't work
because again the corruption in the
system because
the uh
again
the pill
the covet pill that they're working on
it's i think it costs 17 to make and
it's going to sell for over 700.
that's the problem we can't tell the
gougers to stop doing that there's a
different way to get to universal health
care and i think it's really important
because no one's talking about it is
actually you might take the
administrative bureaucracy that's
responsible for administering those
dollars just like the bureaucracy that
administers ppp by the way they waste a
lot of money send it to the wrong places
and i would say let's actually dissolve
that entire apparatus cms center for
medicare medicaid services take the
money and distribute it to the people
who can't afford to buy private health
insurance to actually buy private health
insurance and if you crunch those
numbers it's about five to six thousand
dollars a person but it gets you most of
the way there so get rid of the
bureaucracy and give the money back to
the people that's what i said no what we
need to remove is the profit-making
middleman of insurance companies that's
what needs to be removed but you're
still helping the insurance company
i think the last time i write about
maybe the number is slightly i think
that the profit of the health industry
was something like 11 billion dollars
right and does that sound right i don't
know actually okay and our health care
bill is like two trillion yeah
i'm just saying it's not all there is
it's not all there that's exactly right
i mean it's the same people you're not
ppp that are allocating healthcare
dollars that's the problem it is the
insurance companies yes they did some
terrible things way than they used to
ten years ago when michael moore made
sicko they got away with whatever they
wanted and after that movie things
changed
but
right now it's they we do not stop this
gouging we do not stop i've read this
there's a hospital like in one part of
the city that charges you know eighteen
hundred dollars for a knee replacement
and a hospital
two miles away and it's
fifteen thousand thousand you know i
mean
in the hospital to be in the hospital
and you get the bill and you're like the
slippers are forty-five dollars
and it's the same reason dead people are
getting ppp checks right
it's just and and people go over to
european countries where it's a fraction
of all of that right they do have
socialized medical systems okay but but
what does that mean social why how is
that gonna
stop this i mean if it can yes if that's
what is involved in socialized medicine
i'm all for it so what's going on in
europe though marianne is this is just
an important issue to see for americans
actually to bring money back and this is
one of the things actually would give
even the last administration a good
amount of credit for at least spotting
this issue they're free riding on what
happens in the united states so i ran a
biotech company i can tell you any
company that runs the numbers of whether
a drug is worth developing looks to the
united states first because they know
the united states pays the highest price
if the united states paid the same price
as europe that drug wouldn't have gotten
developed so what europe figured out is
actually the drug is going to get
developed anyway and once the company's
already gotten it to market they're
going to give it to us anyhow so we can
get it cheaper so that's actually what
you're seeing there is gamesmanship on
the part of europe freeriding the
innovation in the united states that's a
complicated issue
and i think the right answers get rid of
the bureaucracy and i'm not arguing with
you about the how [ __ ] up our system
is one reason why we went through this
nightmare with covid is because
hospitals are run like airlines
airlines want to sell every seat
hospitals want every bed filled that's
why oh my god the hospitals are overrun
yes because you don't want to have any
empty beds lying around they want them
to be overrun right they're not overrun
but they want to be at capacity because
that's that's good for the profit
hospitals themselves shouldn't be a
profit thing that's the point i
understand
bill none of it should be about profit
another thing that's really that's
really [ __ ] up about the system is
actually the number of coveted case
counts or cadets due to covet are over
counted because if somebody shows up for
a different cause let's say they're hit
by a car but they ultimately actually
happen to test positive for covid they
actually get higher billing rates in
return for actually counting that person
as positive for covid which just tells
you that people in a system whether or
not we like it respond to incentives we
have to take that into account when we
set up the system that's what i say all
right thank you very much everybody
you